veteran right-hander johnny cueto and
quite a five and three in a 405 era
for the giants so night baseball so one
out
for matt chapman chapman's
not had his typical year he's still a
great defensive third baseman still very
much a threat
doesn't sound like he's having a bad
year hitting 225 nine home runs
2-2 chapman strikes out swinging
that was a good change-up from johnny
cueto long
wait to get the pitch he wanted from
kurt casalli but once he got the one he
wanted he threw a real good one
he threw a real good one so chew down
sean manaya pitching for the athletics
he's had a great year so far
six and three in a 301 era that'll bring
up darren ruff
he delivers and here's the one two to
rough swung out a miss down he goes off
speed
bought over the second he is the giants
nothing nothing crawford leads it off
against mania
night game tomorrow at 705 day game
on sunday at 105. monday's a day off for
the ace here's the 2-2 now and swung out
of this up and in elevated off-speed out
of them
like a slider that backed up or a
change-up but it was up and in
and crawford strikes out that'll bring
up
donovan solano one two pitch swung out
of miss
he chases the high fastball three
strikeouts for mania
and that'll bring up the veteran catcher
kurt casalli a right-handed hitter
here's the delivery now swung out a mess
in a high fastball down he goes
and mania strikes out the side and after
two complete the a's and the giants
don't score
elvis andrews for the a's inning number
three nothing nothing
giants in the athletics the o2 pitch
yeah swung on a missed strike three
cueto got andrews to chase up high
second johnny cueto strikeout now you
don't want shamania to get hurt
as he stands in the bat for the ace
here's the 2-2
swung on lined into right center field
on the run is just
he can't get it it's bye minutes up
against the wall
mania with the hair flying is into
second with a double
shaun manaya shocks the world with an
opposite field
to base it in san francisco he's the a's
first base runner tonight
matt olson grounded out in the first
inning but now a chance to do
real damage bases loaded two down this
is a big moment
early in this game here it comes olson
hits a high fly ball center field not
that deep dubon coming in
he's underneath it he makes a catch for
out number three
that's big great job by johnny cueto
there sort of a combination of bad luck
and some good a's hitting and cueto is
in a jam but he gets through it no runs
allowed
a's leave them loaded we will go to the
bottom of the third nothing nothing
mariano
hit a fly ball to right field leading
off the second inning so he's over one
oakland with lots of power lorriano's
got 13 home runs the athletics
in 77 games have hit 98 home runs
cradle with the shimmy and he struck him
out swinging
with a chain job here comes your stretch
he has the only hits
the only base runner so far tonight for
the giants
here comes the one two swing and a miss
good slider away
that finishes off your strep ski that's
five k's
now for sean brandon struck out his
first time
facing shaun manaya jazz get their first
runner into scoring position
now a swing there's a bloop into shadow
left field it's falling
it's in there base hit coming around
third is
flores and he will score
and that's the first run of the game
brandon crawford who has been the giants
rbi machine
so far and that's his 50th run batted in
of the season that'll bring up sean
manaya who
shocked everybody here with a two base
hit out to right center
in the third inning key to nay's rally
tony kemp is on deck and here's the
one-two fish to sean and that's swing on
dribble toward
third rolling rolling rolling quite a
bear head pickup throws to first too
late
and mania is two for two and here is
matt chapman
this is a similar scenario that
[Applause]
faced when he came up in the third
inning and got an infield hit a slow
slow roller to shortstop olson's been
the big homer in rbi man he's on deck
one and two pitch swinging a mess he
struck it out and he got him to chase a
high fastball up out of the strike zone
and chapman
went after it strikeout number four for
johnny cueto
so now two down and here comes olson
olsen hit a fly ball to center his first
time
or rather his second time when the bases
were loaded
cueto sets at the belt the pitch on the
way
swinging abyss he struck it out on a
high fastball
a little bit up out of the strike zone
fifth strikeout for credo two men
stranded oakland has left
six runners on base in the last three
innings
now to the last of the fifth inning
casalli dubon and cueto
coming up against mania with the giants
leading one to nothing
and cassalli struck out in the second
when manias wrecked out the side he
escaped five
here's the one-two pitch on the way
casali swings
and misses down he goes and ramon
lariano will
lead off here for oakland the
right-hander gets the sign from casalli
goes into his wind-up throws he struck
him out swinging
change up running down and away and
cueto has struck out three
straight athletics going back
to two of their top sluggers chapman and
olson
to end the fifth inning with a couple of
men on so two away
and that'll bring up donovan solano
who's struck out
and hit a comebacker john ready and
here's the one two on the way swung out
of miss
chase is the high fastball and great job
by mania
to work around the walks the two walks
to begin the inning
so the giants fail to score pitchers
duel tonight
after six is cueto and manaya and it's
one nothing giants
so kurt casalli against cam bedrosian
who pitched against the giants earlier
this year and you're thinking well wait
this is
the first meeting between the a's and
the giants where he was with the reds
that ball is hit high in the air left
center field kemp is back
at the warning track at the wall it's
gone
home run for casavi
curt casalli with his second home run of
the year for the giants
two nothing giants chad pinder will try
to keep this game going for oakland
he struck him out the ball game
is over and for the giants
they have shut out the oakland athletics
only the third time this year that
oakland has been shut out